[Music]
You
are the voice in [Music] Hodja Who eat ice Queen first test
walnut jam rims cracker ice Queen
and the enstel belonging to the contributing piece of the
week all cube meat arm Maraş ice cream The
event is out of the company you are not at all age please
remember my name Kanbur I am a
fourth generation ice cream maker
de skype.exe triazine Spider bye Sweet
sound
[Music]
Love was hot right in Foça Jones
Kahramanmaraş Esma cyst ice cream
Capitol Attila Are you incapable of feeding your butter
Operations and blood donuts The
oldest ice cream shop in Maraş
My family is the same
installed capacity per hour 510
Do we make all kinds of
ice cream you can think of, we will put this Maraş ice cream ha streamen,
a tweet listings and test The
milk we use in Morocco is goat milk
, there are plants like thyme and thyme in the mountains of the barn.
not all candies are the same standard that is important to us
examinations in our own laboratory  Let's make
the factory's sugar, we use it if sugar is more suitable for us
Come on, it
won't just be
one of the biggest additives of ice cream,
salep salep
is the bridge part of the wild orchid,
eat that electricity to the ice cream and this time May
instruments R thought the color of the stage and age
Ice kungfu Show
How much ice cream  If you mix it, the
ice cream will be more elastic, both female
Naim Potter on twitter Hizan ice cream and
True and will We also love this job